21 year old Massachusetts Air National
Guardsman Jack joshara was arrested
Thursday after dozens of secret briefing
slides for hundreds of top officials
ended up on a chat app for gamers battle
plans and information related to the war
in Ukraine revealing U.S spying on
adversaries including Russia and China
but also on U.S allies and partners the
Pentagon calls it a very serious risk to
National Security the investigation and
arrest have raised questions about how
the government handles State Secrets
this is about how we practice Safeguard
classified information and as I
highlighted we do have strict protocols
in place so let's look at those
protocols some of which led
investigators to Tashara and how
classified documents are supposed to be
handled
there are three levels of classification
confidential secret and top secret each
indicates how damaging the information
would be to National Security if it were
leaked from damaging to exceptionally
grave this classification is printed on
the top of documents in addition to any
extra designation like SI which stands
for special intelligence information
gained from monitoring foreign
Communications some of the printed
documents allegedly photographed and
posted by Tashara appear marked with SI
and other sensitive classifications
classified documents especially the SI
ones can usually only be accessed in
sensitive compartmented information
facilities or Skiffs by people who were
granted that level of clearance
gifs are secure rooms think the White
House Situation Room where information
can be accessed and discussed securely
there's no cell phones there's no even
smart devices such as fitbits or apple
watches allowed nothing technical that
could allow for the extraction of the
information they can be rooms like these
at the Capitol where senators and house
members must go to view FBI
investigations and other classified
reports they can be fashioned in hotel
rooms or out in fields or they can make
up larger areas inside an entire
building
my office in the last three years I was
a chief of intelligence for the FBI was
a skiff but they all follow the same
protocols and because the sensitive
information can only be accessed in a
skiff it can also only be printed in a
skiff intelligence experts say there's a
technical footprint that begins here
government printers keep detailed logs
of what is printed and by who and some
of these documents people familiar with
the matter said contain invisible or
digital markings too if you're printing
for a specific purpose you would only
print the number of copies for the folks
that would have access to this but when
returned it's put into generally into a
burn bag and then shipped off to an
incinerator that's going to destroy that
information
[Music]
trail that often identifies leakers
in 2017 reality winner a translator
contractor for the National Security
Agency who leaked documents she printed
was quickly identified by tracing the
printer's records
experts like schools say this process is
secure and is good at identifying leaks
but to prevent them in the first place
it relies on trusting the people who are
involved at each step of this process
well there's always going to be human
trust involved in the process the
procedures that were violated who knew
about them what security protocols were
and where this information was accessed
will all be reviewed with likely changes
coming for the Pentagon potentially
others but you're always going to have a
human
aspect to this because that's what the
business is about it's about individuals
being able to access the information
being to the indictment Tashara was
identified through his activities online
and through this security process his
searches on classified Networks
it's unclear what changes may come to
security protocols or to the clearance
of who gets to view these materials in
the wake of toshera's arrest